CBS News has learned police in Idaho
have found a cell phone belonging to one
of two missing children seven year old
JJ valo and his 17 year old sister Kylie
Ryan were last seen in September but in
an eerie development it appears a text
was sent from ty Lee's phone after she
had disappeared
Jonathan Vigliotti is in Rexburg Idaho
for us this morning Jonathan good
morning
where was that phones where was that
phone found yeah good morning to you
Tony first several cell phones including
a laptop were recovered in this
multi-state investigation a source close
to it telling me that ty Lee's phone
appears to have been found with her
mother Lori valo in Hawaii she is a
person of interest in this case
ty Lee's cell phone was used several
times after she disappeared now the
question this morning was it really her
using it on October 25th 2019 a month
after the 17 year old disappeared a text
from her phone was sent to a worried
friend saying hi Missy guys - love you
that friend saying it didn't sound like
her also in October ty Lee's biological
brother says two small venmo payments
were sent from her account this
discovery comes after ty Lee's phone not
only the phone but four items belonging
to her and her 7 year old adopted
brother JJ were discovered abandoned
inside this storage facility valo and
her new husband Chad de Bella prominent
doomsday writer traveled to Hawaii on
November 27th after police conducted a
welfare check on Bella's Idaho townhouse
both have denied any wrongdoing the
children are still missing
they have not been seen in Hawaii an
investigator tells me a teenager without
her cell phone is a disturbing new
development it has been five months Kel
since anyone has seen these two children
it's a mystery and it does not sound
good thank you very much Jonathan